welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of loki
episode 6 the season finale for
all time always which deprives us of jet
ski mobius but makes up for it with
jonathan major's wickedly talented
performance as he who remains
a variant of kang the conqueror look
there's so much deeper meaning hidden in
all the details of this episode so let's
break down this finale frame by frame to
celebrate me getting the theory right
for a change
also you can get our loki inspired merch
at newrockstarsmerch.com like our loki
out of time shirt and our loki gator
polo and a moby's on a jet ski shirt but
the window is closing fast so you gotta
jump on this norockstarsmerch.com
okay over the marvel studios title we
actually hear the music of it's been a
long long time by harry james and helen
forrest which first played in captain
america the winter soldier and then more
memorably in the final scene of avengers
endgame that was the moment steve rogers
created one of the many variant branches
that could have destabilized he who
remains sacred timeline
then we hear other iconic sounds from
mcu past which at first play
over the character as they appeared in
the marvel title animation but then
build into a cacophony as the timeline
orbits around his citadel in a flat
circle
time unfolding all at once from his
perspective but because i'm insane i've
broken down
pretty much everything hidden in here
iron man's repulsor
[Music]
falcon congratulated ant-man during
civil war way to go tic-tac way to go
zig-zag hope van dyne's lying to scott
lang and ant-man that's how you punch
that's how you punch hulk roaring
t'challa's salute in black panther
spider-man's web shooter
scott's first meeting with falcon and
ant-man you wouldn't have heard of me
no you wouldn't have heard of me natasha
talking to coulson in avengers
let me put you on hand let me put you on
hold peter quill in guardians of the
galaxy dance off bro
dance off bro me and you thor in
ragnarok he's a friend from work
he's a friend from work cap versus cap
and in-game i can do this all day yeah i
know
i can do this all day yeah i know i know
mjolnir i think reverting to cap and end
game
younger hank pym and ant-man i'll show
you ferocity
and i'll show you ferocity carol danvers
and captain marvel hire further faster
baby
hire further faster baby that's right
loki two thanos and infinity war
we have a water we have a hulk korg the
loki and ragnarok we're gonna jump on
that spaceship and get out of here
we're about to jump on that ginormous
spaceship you want to come bucky and
winter soldier
who the hell is bucky peter quill
planning and guardians of the galaxy
i have part of a plan natasha deloke in
avengers
i got red in my ledger i'd like to wipe
it out doctor strange to dormammu
[Music]
i've come to bargain vision to ultron
i was born yesterday hulk to loki and
avengers
puny god thor to that shield big guy
in thor you're big
fought bigger fury's speech and avengers
there was an idea stark knows this
hawkeye speech to one to an ultron
you are an avenger loki's final words in
infinity war
[Music]
banners big line in avengers my secrets
that's my secret captain
i'm always angry hank pym and ant-man
and the wasp
[Music]
you sent my suit for the mail and it
sounds like the voice of carly
morgenthau in there from falcon winter
soldier
and kaiselius to dr strange
the time is the true enemy of us all
time kills everything
and then it ends with a subtle baby
crystal
now this one is actually hard to find
but it is the sound of baby loki crying
in that flashback and thor of odin
taking him in when he was a frost giant
ward
now you'll notice there's a bit of a
low-key bias among these since
this history is being filtered through
the perspective of a witness
observing loki's entire life start to
finish in particular
then we pull out from our solar system
now hearing a lecture from philosopher
alan watts about time
watts argued that time isn't really the
past causing the events of the future
but in truth just an imaginary concept
that we perceive from where we are in
the present similar to the non-linear
way
he who remains perceives time and then
we zoom out from the galaxy and we hear
neil armstrong's first words on the moon
meanwhile a mysterious ship soars past
us now this doesn't look like any of the
guardians of the galaxy's ships
nor one that nasa would use or one that
i think sword would use
especially this far out in the solar
system but i'm thinking it could be one
piloted by
kang enemies the fantastic four then we
hear the voice of climate activist greta
thundberg
as all of the galaxies our known
universe appears to be contained within
this blue sphere which then condenses
and then explodes maybe a depiction of a
big bang or a future big bang an event
that would have created the infinity
stones then we hear the voice of
activist malala yousafzai
then the voice of nelson mandela we have
fought for the right
to experience speech as tchaikovsky's
music from swan lake plays
representing a battle between light and
dark like the apathetic yet so
benevolent variant
of kang vs the darker more menacing
variants who end up conquering
in the end we realize everything we have
just seen has been set inside of one
black hole
that neighbors another as the music
shifts like a radio dial to beethoven's
pure release
experience
which he wrote as an ode to his lover
perhaps reflecting the way kang's
actions may have been
fury ravonna everything we're seeing
here is really an astronomical geography
of the spatial relationship between
these universes which he who remains
later describes as stacked on top of
each other and then we dive into that
second black hole a separate reality now
as we hear the voice of classic loki
from last episode
and then we briefly see one planet
colliding into another perhaps this was
lamentous one
and then we stretch into a by frosty
2001 space odyssey stargate as we hear
first liberian president ellen johnson
sir leaves 2006 speech motivated
by women
motivated by women throughout the world
and then visions big line from one
division what is grief
if not love perseverance what is grief
if not love persevering
and then poet maya angelou that was from
a poem with verses about her history
being rewritten
which does happen to sylvia and loki at
the end of this episode when no one
remembers them
the final things we hear during this
montage are silvie's voice from last
episode
open your eyes open your eyes and then
some morse code beep
this could be the 1962 morse message
that was beamed out to space
and we see the citadel at the end of
time with this cracked
design which is also reflected in he who
remains time twister on his wrist and
his tableau
goo looks a lot like kintsugi pottery
representing how he who remains likely
had to piece it together from broken
shards of that past multiversal war
to create this kind of neutral ground
and foreshadowing the way that this
timeline will
splinter and crack once more in the
episode's end flanking this entrance are
two giant hourglasses
and staying true to this series wizard
of oz parallels their slow walk down the
hall does mirror the nervous walk to
meet the wizard
just reveal that man behind the curtain
is a far more comedic figure than we
expected but before we even get there
miss minute scares the [ __ ] out of us
in this chamber with looming hooded
figures with clocks for
faces kind of like a creepier form of
what miss minutes essentially is a
clock-faced greeter and note how later
she's
late to meet rinslayer therefore she
cannot be in two places at once
and she offers them this deal he's
worked it out so we can reinsert
both of y'all back into the timeline in
a way that
won't disrupt things similar to the
offer made in the matrix to the humans
really this whole episode is kind of
playing out like the architect scene and
matrix reloaded but a lot more fun to
watch miss minutes offers loki his
chance to rule
you can kill thanos
yeah natalie holds violin theme returns
the music that played over loki watching
his own life back in episode one
but not to his own death but to the
deaths of friega and odin
that is who he is really thinking about
in this moment a chance to see them in
thor again
now trailer footage showed some shots of
king loki on the asgardian throne and
back at the top of stark tower
presumably these were going to be shown
here as loki imagined these
possibilities now back at the tva
rensselaer notices mobius ring stains on
the table something that he did not
remember leaving which could connect to
his total memory reset
at the end of this episode make me
wonder if the tva could have been reset
before all this
many times similar to how in the matrix
that was actually the sixth incarnation
of the matrix ravana gets a mystery file
he thinks this will be more useful who
yeah notice how here rensselaer does not
seem to know who he who remains
is but in the later scene she suddenly
seems more agitated and she gripes that
he's the only one with free will
so what did she learn from this file
well later mobius reveals that ren
slayer actually came from fdr high
school in fremont ohio in 2018
where she was apparently the principal
based on her having an office and that
ohio state diploma
listing her name as rebecca torminae an
alias that rinslayer actually uses in
the comics when she goes to the year
1903.
so i love it she goes from a name
sounding like terminate to one sounding
like slayer now on her desk you'll see
more pens like the one that we saw
and around this school are posters of
fdr but also eleanor roosevelt naropas
and then a bunch more posters of coat
drives
and this being homecoming week and that
is interesting because homecoming is of
course normally in the autumn but autumn
2018
in the mcu would have been a few months
after the snap which occurred in the
spring of that year so perhaps this coat
drive is for displaced kids and families
during the blip
and the reason she joined the tva could
have been blip related because ravana
ranslayer is of course kang's love
interest in the comics so maybe here in
the show he has something
over her like she could have been
destined to have been dusted and that
could have left behind a child who died
without her
so to keep her sacred timeline self
undusted and that kid's safe she
continues to work for kang
as his objectified doll i have to
believe they had a reason but here upon
learning this truth she leaves through
this time
door where are you gonna go in search of
free will
which could be her searching for a
reality with a different kang variant
who might give her a better deal which
could lead to the kang the conqueror who
overtakes the tva in the final scene by
the way most of us have a goal that we
want to accomplish but for some reason
we haven't yet right maybe it seems
overwhelming or you're just not excited
enough to start well the hero's journal
helps by turning your goal into a quest
and thanks to hero's journal for
sponsoring this episode
based on the best of goal-setting
psychology and the story theory behind
your favorite fandoms the hero's journal
will help you discover the story you
tell about yourself and define the quest
you want to undertake whether your goals
revolve around
improving your health or taking a step
forward in your career or finally
undertaking a big creative project the
hero's journal guides you along the
journey to achieving your goal
check it out each page contains unique
art that progresses as you turn the page
there are dragons and castles other fun
fantasy imagery that puts your personal
challenge into a more heroic context and
finishing that novel seems a lot cooler
when you
are doing it in arthurian style and the
exterior of the journal is just super
cool it feels more like a sacred
tone than just a journal and what's
really cool about the heroes journal is
that it builds a positive narrative
about productivity versus you know like
a shame based narrative and you get to
feel good about all the tiny steps that
you're taking on a daily basis so the
heroes journal is available for purchase
now just head to heroesjournal.co or
click the link in the description and
use our promo code new rockstars for
your 10
off but back in the citadel loki and
silvie reach a chamber with the ceiling
cogs and pendulums bells but then on the
floor a depiction of the lunar cycle
all of these are various ways of keeping
time but also time keeper statues
three still standing but a fourth one
shattered in the comics there was a
fourth time keeper named the oracle of
siwa who is
exiled to ancient egypt for informing
the fantastic four of events to come
perhaps this statue was shattered during
the past multiversal war between kangs
and he who remains couldn't put it back
together or this could be some evidence
of a past
attempted uprising in one of the past
tva resets where one of the time keepers
betrayed he who remains to help a
variant get to him
and then he who remains responded by
expelling that one faulty timekeeper
and destroying his statue that
represented him but then the man behind
the curtain we've been talking about is
revealed
he will revenge she's still calling me
out
creepy right look
i like it yes he who remains is actually
the name of the elderly tva caretaker at
the citadel the end of time
who builds the timekeepers in the comics
and although he's never explicitly named
kang in this episode he who remains is
100
confirmed to be a variant of kang the
conqueror jonathan magers was cast as
kang for ant-man the was quantomania he
is dressed like immortus who is another
form of kang from the comics
he said that his variant was from the
31st century when kang nathaniel
richards was born
he calls himself a conqueror and yeah
this pays off all the clues the show has
given us from rentslayer to eliath to
the tower for kang enterprises the shell
company
rensselaer's id of a23 which was their
appearance together in the comics
avengers 23 and notice how here the
light
casts his face in blue like his comic
book look now i notice he eats an
apple which could mean a lot of things
first it's a symbol of newtonian
knowledge
you know boink and later on in his
office is this chalkboard with equations
that use integrals and if i remember
from calculus a b in high school this is
calculus
and jurassic newton is credited as a
co-creator of calculus but the apple
also recalls doctor strange's use of an
apple to first demonstrate time
manipulation in the mcu
but also reminds us of that episode two
word problem for miss minutes that asked
about the last
mcu big bad thanos using him eating
apples as an example
of course apples are also associated
with the forbidden fruit of the garden
of eden in the book of genesis
used to tempt adam and eve by the
serpent and in this episode he who
remains
offers these adam and eve figures
chances to be gods
and refers to himself a few times this
episode as the devil now to pull off
this effect that he remains dodging
sylvie's blows
hiddleston and demartino must have had
to shoot their action on a green screen
and then had to be layered into that
elevator with magers but this render was
left
just rough enough around the edges that
leaves the characters and us
feeling emotionally detached from this
seemingly untouchable immortal
he who remains reveals this is all
scripted and we see if you look closely
at his book that sylvia is id'd as
variant
and notice how he lifts that book i like
how he does a subtle little adjustment
of his time twister to draw attention to
it since this is the key to controlling
the room
and i think he ultimately wants sylvia
to take it and kill him so that he can
respawn in a more dangerous form
like i think the council of kangs know
that loki and silvi's union
make them true nexus beings that
threaten their empire and so he who
remains really feigns this candidness
with this phony offer to replace him
while really he is driving a wedge
between them the whole
time it's all a manipulation
interesting that your head
would go to that
sylvie you think you can trust this guy
he who remains later says without the
tva everything burns jonathan majors is
having a blast
hamming up the eccentricities in this
jaded sing-songy tone
he's constantly moving to new
physicalities just to punctuate and live
in this monologue kind of like a guy on
the last day of his job super dangerous
super fun to watch
you could actually compare him to heath
ledger's joker who also says similar
words
everything burns and when he's seated at
his desk he's framed with his head in
the middle of his spiral window in the
background
kind of like the whole universe orbiting
around his egomaniacal personality and
he explains a variant of himself in the
31st century discovered parallel
universes the same time as other
variants
for a while there was peace narcissistic
self-congratulatory peace i love your
shoes i love your hair oh man nice nose
thanks man yeah majors might be joking
about his own recognizable nose but
really he knows he is
sexy we see how the kang variants
invented time doors
reset charges the computers pruning
sticks the tva used but they ended up
in this multiversal war meaning that
miss minute's animation was actually
telling the truth about that
just that it wasn't the time keepers who
ended it but he who remains
apparently repelling these even worse
evil kings
[Music]
the figurines shape-shift into prayerful
and grateful poses
he says i've lived a million lifetimes
i've gone through every every scenario
this is
the only way similar to how dr strange
said that he saw 14 million 605 future
outcomes but that only one was a
successful way forward
there was no other way now of course he
remains his offer is very much like a
willy wonka style offer to them to take
over his job but i love how majors nods
at that with his pose here
or you're a liar
or malaya yeah leaning on his fist just
like the willy wonka meme
and as he says he is older than he looks
and that this game is for the young and
hungry the camera pulls back from him
making him look smaller and smaller and
more diminished in the window spiral
as if his influence is appearing to fade
then he snaps at sylvie grow up
grow up sylvie murderer hypocrite
similar to how kaiselius called out the
ancient one hypocrite
because among sorcerers no one really
has the moral high ground but then
everything shifts in this scene but now
we
you have a chance to do them for a good
reason
we just crossed the threshold
yeah that thunder was the sound of the
sacred timeline breaking up
and fitting to use thunder for that
because as it branches it does look a
lot like heat lightning evoking the
moment the ancient one
slowed down time in the moment of her
death a similar moment where she
just like he who remains here could not
foresee beyond that point so what caused
this
ravona's pact with another kang or could
he who remains justifying free will
subversion
had been the thing that sylvie decided
she was just gonna kill him no matter
what loki told her either way
that break makes it so that when loki
returns to the tva
it has already warped and reset so that
a different kang
is now ruling over this one he remains
removes his time twister and slides it
over but notice how his gesture
again sliding his hand across the table
and the framing makes it look like
it is still on his hand which could be a
clue that this offer is really a bait
and switch because both alternatives
lead to his victory loki and sylvie duel
upon their early clash he remains jumps
in his seat in the corner in excitement
which is similar to how palpatine loved
watching luke invader fight
before that anakin and dooku fight
because either way the mastermind is
already won
it's so tragic to see these two fight
largely in the way it parallels what
loki told silvi as an answer to what
love is back in episode 3.
love is a dagger it's a weapon
to be wielded far away or up close
you can see yourself in it it's
beautiful until it makes you bleed
but ultimately when you reach for it
it isn't real yeah loki wields his love
for silvia up close
and he can see himself in her but she
makes him bleed
and when he reaches for it it isn't real
instead classic loki's wisdom really
reigns supreme the blades
are worthless in the face of a loki
sorcery but despite all this loki does
make a key concession
all i know is i don't want to hurt you
i don't want a throne i just want you to
be okay
signaling that he learned the core
lesson that sylvie laid out for him
earlier this season this isn't about you
but as he tumbles back through the time
door into the tva theater the window
lights on the floor go in opposing
directions which is odd because
presumably they're coming from the same
exterior light source the way these
lights paralleled loki and mobius's
opposition episode four they now mirror
the opposition between loki and silvi
but on a more literal level it also
shows how this new tva that loki has
found himself in
does not revolve according to the same
gravity as the old one did so sylvie
stabs he who remains
and he winks and says see you soon
yeah back in episode 4 after sylvie
beheaded the timekeeper android and the
other two shut down
if you listen closely you could hear a
voice whisper
see you soon
yes the voice of kang he who remains who
was calling his shot back then
and now his wink confirming it to her
that she truly has had no free will in
this battle the sacred timeline splits
into branches of branches of branches
and the chrono monitor screen confirms
that many of these branches overlap
with each other and looking back at the
cosmic version of it some regions grow
a bright red which could be the
incursion that we saw in wanda vision's
post-credits scene and been the cause of
wanda suddenly hearing her children
calling to her from another reality
so yes we are looking at the multiverse
of madness that doctor strange two will
take place in where the scar the witch
will be the rising threat he has to face
perhaps even the logical basis for
howard alfred molina doc
och and jamie fox electro will appear in
spider-man no way home hopefully we get
a trailer for that very soon meanwhile
loki finds the tva
changed as he passes a bunch of hunters
who don't really care about him
it's hard to tell but one of these must
be hunter k5e
copy reporting listed in the credits as
eugene cordero meaning casey must have
either got promoted or
in this alternate tva instead of being a
desk clerk he gets to be a hunter
and then in the archives he finds mobius
and b15 who have no idea who he is which
is really odd because even before he was
a detained variant loki was the freaking
god of mischief with an infamous
reputation so this must have been a hard
memory wipe reset the timekeeper statues
have been replaced with
he who remains variant in this case it
is kang the conqueror which we know
because he's wearing his conqueror
wardrobe this might remind you of that
final twist in tim burton's 2001
planet of the apes with the lincoln
memorial but just by looking at this
while the tva may change on a dime its
true creator is now
thanks to sylvie for all time always and
the credits confirm that loki will
return for a second season and with
kang's confirmed appearance in ant-man
the watts quantomania in february 2023
i'm thinking season two could come at
the end of 2022 or maybe in the first
weeks of 2023 to lead into that film
ant-man the wasp left a quantum realm
city in the background that i've been
theorizing could be
kang's kingdom of chronopolis and kang
and quantomania could live beyond that
film to be the villain of a future
fantastic four film
or an avengers secret wars conflict but
whenever we see kang next with an actor
as talented and versatile as jonathan
majors it would not surprise me if he
brings a whole new characterization to
his conqueror variant we still have much
to learn about him
and that is what makes him so dangerous
and so delightful
i want to thank you all so much for
joining me on these breakdowns of loki
this show is a true master class in
world building and storytelling and i
hope the details and connections i've
been able to find have enriched the
viewing experience for you
don't worry i'll be back with plenty
more marvel theories and future
breakdowns so be sure to subscribe to
new rockstars follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos follow new rockstars
thank you again for watching bye
[Music]
you